quand j'avais constaté que ce genre de
manifestation n'existait pas en
martinique alors qu'en métropole c'est
très courant il y en a de plus en plus
donc j'ai proposé au président de fortis
de faire cette organisation est depuis
quinze ans il existe désormais avec de
plus en plus de
deux candidats cette épreuve
cette année les parrains ce sera donc
deux parce que en fait on a voulu faire
plaisir à la fdj et il y aura
le père et le fils madouas le père a été
professionnel pendant plusieurs années
au sein de l'équipe castorama notamment
il a disputé plusieurs tours de france
et tour d'italie et le fils aîné aux
professionnels il a fait une très très
belle saison cette année
notamment il a gagné paris bourges
dernièrement la et 6e de paris-tours
donc c'est un très grand espoir du
cyclisme français
c'est pas une vraie compétition si on
veut ça fait à l'image des marathons et
à celui qui veut faire la corse et puis
celui qui veut se faire plaisir et se
mesurer par rapport aux licenciés ça
veut dire que c'est ouvert à tout le
monde
bien sûr ceux qui sont pas licenciés qui
font du vélo occasionnellement le
dimanche et cela permet de se mesurer à
des licenciés de notoriété pour voir un
petit peu où ils en sont la 16e édition
sera une course à la fois je dirais un
triptyque avec trois volets c'est à dire
que désormais il ya deux circuits il ya
un circuit de 70 km pour ceux qui
veulent pas faire la grande distance et
un circuit plus long qui va
jusqu'au robert et qui revient par gros
morneau et qui fait 105 km donc il ya
une lycéenne
c'est la première compétition c'est la
première épreuve alors en fait il ya des
préparations c'est à dire la lucéenne
elle a lieu le dimanche qui précède
et après le 11 novembre c'est toujours
le 11 novembre label martinique et le
dimanche qui suit il ya là robert la
cyclo du robert